مع انتهاء بثنا اليوم، لدي
ملاحظة شخصية أود مشاركتها
معك. أريد أن أبدأ بفعل
هذا وأطلب منك معروفًا كبيرًا، فقط
خذ ثانية لتذكر أسماء
ثماني نساء تحبهن وتعرفينهن.
حياتك ثمانية فقط عدهم على
أصابعك إحصائيا واحد منهم سيصاب
بسرطان الثدي أو سيصاب به أنا واحد
من كل ثمانية في مجموعة أصدقائي لم
أمرض يوما في حياتي لا أدخن
نادرا ما أشرب سرطان الثدي  لا
ينتشر في عائلتي ومع ذلك فأنا مصابة
بسرطان الثدي في المرحلة الثالثة، ومن الصعب أن
أقول بصوت عالٍ إنني في الشهر الثاني من
العلاج الكيميائي وسنقوم بالإشعاع، كما أن
المرحلة الثالثة لاستئصال العضلة المزدوجة لم تعد
حكمًا بالإعدام بعد الآن.
الغالبية العظمى من النساء ولكن هذه هي
الحقيقة التي صدمت نظامي حقًا
عندما بدأت البحث عن المزيد
حول سرطان الثدي، وهو شيء لم أكن
أعرفه من قبل قبل هذا التشخيص. إذا
كنت امرأة سوداء، فأنت
أكثر عرضة للوفاة بسبب الثدي بنسبة 41٪.
السرطان أكثر من نظرائك البيض بنسبة
41%، لذا إلى جميع أخواتي السود والبيض
والبني هناك، من فضلك، من أجل محبة
الله، احصلي على تصوير الثدي بالأشعة السينية كل
عام، قم بإجراء اختباراتك الذاتية وحاولي اكتشافه
قبل أن أفعل الآن، إليك شيء لم
أستطع فعله أبدًا  لقد توقعت أن يحدث
لي، لقد شكرت السرطان لأنه
اختارني، أتعلم أنه بغض النظر عن
الجحيم الذي نمر به في
الحياة، فأنا ما زلت أحب
هذه الحياة بجنون، ومجرد كوني على قيد الحياة يبدو
مختلفًا حقًا بالنسبة لي الآن أنا أكثر سعادة.
لأنني لا أشدد على
الأشياء الصغيرة الحمقاء التي كانت تزعجني،
والآن كل يوم أتنفس فيه
نفسًا آخر، يمكنني الاحتفال بأنني ما
زلت هنا معك، أنا هنا مع
زملائي، زملائي وعائلتي
ويمكنني ذلك  الحب والبكاء والضحك والأمل
وهذا يا أصدقائي الأعزاء
يكفي